Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass mit seiner Ausgabe 193. Wir wollen auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen gucken in unserem beliebten Format Ligatour, zu dem ich euch sehr herzlich begrüße. Und jetzt geht's los. Es wird mal wieder Zeit hier im Rasenfunk auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen zu gucken. Wir wollen schauen auf die Premier League, auf die Serie A, auf die Liga, auf La Liga. Wie immer habe ich dazu eine Reihe von Gästen, die ich gleich mit dem Plädoyer hier begrüßen werde. Das wird unser Einstieg. Ich begrüße zum einen Alex Truica ist da für La Liga. Was hast du denn uns für Themen mitgebracht?
Hola, buenas. Ja, viele Themen aus Spanien. Denn da wird sehr viel Fußball gespielt. Und zwar nicht nur in La Liga, sondern Copa del Rey, Super Copa, Liga. Da geht es drunter und drüber. Sehr Salami-Spieltag. Da gibt es einiges zu besprechen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt auf die Salami-Spieltage in diesem ansonsten rein vegetarischen, weil ja, Rasenfunk. Haha, das geht schon mal hier großartig los. Hendrik Buchheister kann sich kaum den Bauch halten vorlachen, ob dieses Witzes Premier League ist bei dir das Thema. Was hast du uns mitgebracht für diese Sendung?
Genau, also wir müssen natürlich sprechen über den Meisterschaftskampf, der Anfang Dezember noch sehr, sehr offen schien und plötzlich komplett entschieden ist, zugunsten von Manchester City. Und dann natürlich sprechen können wir auch über den FC Everton, der mal wieder einen Trainer gefeuert hat, mal wieder einen großen Namen als Trainer gefeuert hat, nämlich Rafa Benitez, der vor der Saison erst kam und jetzt schon wieder weg ist.
Ja, da haben wir die klassischen Themen einer Fußballliga. Das ist doch schön, dass es sowas auch mal gibt. Und dann begrüße ich sehr für die Ligue 1 Alexis Menuge. Alexis, was hast du uns heute mitgebracht?
Ja, drei heiße Themen, natürlich immer Paris Saint-Germain, warum diese milliardäre Mannschaft immer noch nicht funktioniert, warum Monaco Kovac entlassen hat, obwohl gar nicht so verkehrt dargestellt in der Tabelle, dass er gehen musste am 30. Dezember. Und dazu noch die neue Macht nach Paris heißt Nizza. Das würde ich gerne sagen. Warum es nachhaltig sein wird.
Sehr gut, sehr interessant.
Vielleicht, wenn du mir erlaubst, vielleicht die Abschlussfrage dieser Sendung. Es ist überhaupt keine Spannung in allen Legen. Tut mir leid, Christian, aber du weißt auch, dass Inter da funktionieren wird und warum die Super League kommen muss.
Warum die Super League kommen muss. Sehr schön. Da habt ihr jetzt ein bisschen Zeit, euch darauf vorzubereiten. Vorher darf dann gerade noch Christian, der hier neben mir sitzt, in den Rasenfunk-Headquarters. Christian, was hast du uns mitgebracht? Hallo Max, hallo in die Runde. Ja, ich würde sagen, seit gestern Abend müssen wir über eine Schiedsrichterentscheidung sprechen, die Italien sehr beschäftigt. Milan war leidtragend gestern Abend. Dadurch auch das Thema Meisterschaftskampf, da mit Inter auch ein Thema. Dann sollten wir kurz über den FC Genua sprechen, denn da ist anscheinend Bruno Labbadia im Anmarsch. Und da gibt es einiges zu sagen. Und ich würde gerne über einen Herren namens Ivan Juric sprechen, den Trainer des FC Turin, mit dem man dann gleich zwei Vereine verknüpfen kann, nämlich Hellas Verona, von dem er vor der Saison kam. Und die sind beide in einer richtig guten Verfassung, was meiner Meinung nach sehr viel mit dem Namen Ivan Juric zu tun hat. Na, da haben wir doch so einige Themen, die wir besprechen können.
Dann lass uns doch mal reinstarten.
Alex, du darfst mal anfangen. Wir haben verschiedene Pokalwettbewerbe gesehen, nicht alle in Spanien ausgespielt. Was ist denn wichtig, darüber zu wissen?
Ich fange mal mit den sachlichen Dingen an. Real Madrid ist Super Copa-Gewinner. Das interessiert wahrscheinlich in Deutschland nicht so viele Leute. Dieser Super Cup hat aber wesentlich mehr Bedeutung in Spanien. Da ist das wirklich ein Titel, mit dem sich die Vereine gerne schmücken. Real Madrid hat ihn ziemlich zelebriert im Finale, den Athletik-Club aus Bilbao geschlagen. Und im Halbfinale, fast der wichtigere Sieg, den Klassikog gegen Barca gewonnen. Hierzulande war das leider nicht zu sehen. Also weder Klassikos noch Super Copa-Finale da, das niemand übertragen hat. Aber es war ein flottes Turnier hier. So viel kann man schon sagen.
Kannst du erklären, woher das kommt, dass es so eine größere Bedeutung hat in Spanien?
Also grundsätzlich, was sie jetzt gemacht haben, ist, es gibt einen Final-Four-Turnier mit Halbfinale und Finale, ähnlich wie beim Handball in der Champions League. Das wärtet das ganze sportlich, glaube ich, ein bisschen auf. Weil du einfach mehr Spiele hast, logischerweise. Dann hast du in der Regel einen Klassiker oder du hast das Derby Madrileño zwischen Atletico und Real Madrid. Oder du hast ein Baskenduell oder überhaupt. Oder auch Atletico Barca. Also sehr viele spannende Spiele, spannende Match-ups, Rivalitäten. Das sorgt natürlich dafür, dass die jeweiligen Spiele auch ein bisschen aufgewertet wird, dass die Mannschaften diese Spiele auch ernster nehmen. Dann hast du natürlich die Chance für zwei der vier Vereine, die es in der Regel nicht gewohnt sind, regelmäßig Titel zu gewinnen, dass sie mal einen Titel gewinnen können. Also beispielsweise Atletico Bilbao war dieses Jahr im Finale, hat letztes Jahr den Superpokal sogar gewonnen. Ich glaube, das wäre der erste Pokalsieg überhaupt in Spanien für die Basten seit 20, 30, 40 Jahren. Also auch wenn es nur ein Supercup ist, die Bedeutung eines Pokalsiegs, egal welcher Pokal, ist für so einen Verein, der einfach nichts gewinnen kann, weil die großen Real Barca und Atletico zu übermächtig sind, dadurch hat dieser Wettbewerb wesentlich mehr Bedeutung. Und so kommt eins zum anderen. Rivalitäten, wie gesagt, spannende Spiele. Dann grundsätzlich ist die Supercoppa auch immer eine spannende Sache. Jetzt wird sie auch unter der Saison ausgetragen, im Januar. Dadurch hat sie weniger diesen Freundschaftsspiel-Charakter, wie in Deutschland, wo sie vor der Liga irgendwann im August oder so ausgetragen wird. Dann ist das ein besseres Freundschaftsspiel. Jetzt ist man mitten in der Saison. Die Mannschaften stehen im Saft. Die besten Spieler spielen. Und so kommt eins zum anderen, glaube ich.
Wie qualifiziert man sich dafür?
Der Pokalsieger nimmt teil, der Meister nimmt teil und dann der Vizepokalsieger und der Tabellenzweite der letzten Saison.
Hendrik, das würde mich mal interessieren. Ich würde es gerne auch gleich noch bei den anderen Ligen auch erfahren. In der Premier League oder in England ist es ja so, dass die Pokale auch wesentlich wichtiger sind und gefühlt werden da auch 15 Pokale ausgespielt. Ganz so schlimm ist es nicht. Es wirkt nur so wegen Hin- und Rückspiel. Warum gibt es da so unterschiedliche Ansätze? Kannst du das mal für England beantworten?
Ja, in England ist es so, dass die FA natürlich ihren traditionellen Pokal hat, den FA Cup. Und der natürlich für die FA auch nach wie vor eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Gerade nachdem die Premier League ja mittlerweile so in England so eine enorme Bedeutung eingenommen hat, dass die FA natürlich auch immer noch einen Wettbewerb haben möchte, den man vorzeigen kann. Das ist ja dieser FA Cup, der wird auch von den Clubs ernst genommen. Also den FA Cup zu gewinnen oder im Finale in Wembley zu spielen, das ist auch immer noch eine große Sache. Da gibt es den Liga-Pokal von der EFL, der immer so ein bisschen verlacht wird und immer auch als notwendiges Übel angesehen wird, weil er, wie du es halt sagst, mit jedem Rückspiel ganz schön den Spielplan blockiert, weil er auch früher schon gespielt wird. Also das Finale ist immer deutlich früher. Da sind jetzt schon die Halbfinals. Was natürlich gerade im Moment, wo der Spielplan eh schon überfüllt ist und die Corona-Ausbrüche ja auch grassieren in den Mannschaften oder grassiert haben zuletzt, eine erhebliche Belastung bedeutet. Aber man hat auch in den letzten Jahren gesehen, dass gerade die großen Clubs diesen Liga-Pokal, auch immer noch ein Sponsor benannt wird, also im Moment Carabao, ein Energy-Drink-Hersteller, dass dieser Pokal aber auch wichtiger geworden ist für die großen Clubs in den letzten Jahren. Also gerade Manchester City hat sich bis zur Angewohnheit gemacht, auch diesen Liga-Pokal zu gewinnen, um dann zu sagen, man hat schon mal den ersten Pokal im Sack, sozusagen, bevor es dann in die wirklich entscheidende Phase der Saison, in der Liga, in der Champions League geht.
Alexi, wie ist das in der Liga 1? Welche Pokale habt ihr da?
Wir hatten zwei sogar. Den Liga-Pokal, der abgeschafft wurde, weil einfach mit einer 20er Liga plus Coupe de France plus Coupe de la Liga, so Liga-Pokal und der normale Pokal, das war einfach zu viel. Und dieser Liga-Pokal, das waren nur die 20 Liga-Mannschaften plus 12 aus der 2. Liga. Und da gab es so eine Qualifikationsrunde für die 2. Ligisten. Und ja, das war immer ein Spiel, also keine Hin- und Rückspiele, aber den haben wir abgeschafft, weil einfach der Kalender zu heftig wurde. Und auch die finanziellen Mittel, die der Liga-Verband zur Verfügung hatte, waren einfach zu gering, sodass man den vor drei Jahren abgeschafft hat.
Und der 2.
Stadt de France ist natürlich eine Tradition. Genau, das ist eine große Tradition in Frankreich. Finale wird immer im Paris, Paris Stadt de France, normalerweise bestritten. Die letzten Jahre hat man aber in der Provinz ein bisschen umgestellt, weil nicht immer alles in Paris. Aber dieser Wettbewerb hat schon große Bedeutung, nur das kleine Problem ist, dass immer Paris St. Germain den gewinnt.
Wie ist es in der Serie A, Christian? Ich kann mich dabei Alex anschließen, denn auch in Italien wurde letzte Woche der Super Cup ausgespielt, zwar zwischen Inter und Juve. Inter hat ihn gewonnen durch ein Tor in der 121. Minute von Alexis Sanches, als schon alles mit Meifmeterschießen rechnete. Und ich würde auch sagen, die Bedeutung ist auch in Italien, ähnlich wie in Spanien, höher. Man hat das vor allem jetzt bei dem Finale gesehen, Inter ist mit voller Kapelle aufgetreten, obwohl sie am Wochenende davor gegen Lazio gespielt haben und jetzt am Wochenende jetzt am Zurückkling gegen Atalanta, also auch mitten in einer sehr intensiven englischen Woche. Und man hat auch nur Simone Entsage, den Inter-Trainer, nach fünf Minuten an der Seitenlinie sehen müssen, wie viel Engagement, wie viel Emotion dabei war. Und das kommt logisch auch aus der Geschichte heraus. Inter hat letztes Jahr den großen Juwezug gestoppt nach neun Jahren Meistertiteln. Und jetzt fühlt sich Inter eben auch mit dieser Stärke oder vom Gefühl her, dass sie vielleicht jetzt eine Serie starten können. Und dann hat man ganz genau gemerkt, das war wirklich emotional, wie Inter das Ding dann knapp gewinnt. Juwe hat es richtig gut gemacht. Weil ich glaube, bei der momentanen Verfassung hätten jetzt nicht alle damit gerechnet, dass Juwe da 120 Minuten mithält. Und dann hat man gesehen, was bei Inter sich da entladen hat, weil es eben auch darum geht, sozusagen vielleicht oder nicht nur vielleicht den großen Rivalen klarzumachen. Schaut mal her, ihr wart der Platzhirsch, wir sind der Neue, der hier das Kommando übernimmt. Und es war diesmal wieder in Italien, nicht in Saudi-Arabien was ausgespielt. Sehr schön, ja. Das ist vielleicht eine der, ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, dass Corona positive Nebeneffekte hat, aber diese Geschichte kommt daher, dass auch die italienische Liga verstanden hat, dass man mitten einer Pandemie vielleicht nicht für so ein Spiel noch mal auf die arabische Halbinsel fliegen sollte oder müsste. Dementsprechend war es in San Siro auch ein richtig schöner, ja, toller Rahmen und war ein sehr spannendes Spiel. Und wie gesagt, für Inter glaube ich eben noch mal so ein emotionaler Push, so, okay, wir haben jetzt gerade erst angefangen, wir haben uns auf eine Reise begeben. Wurde ja von Marius Seuke in der letzten Ligatur auch schon angekündigt. Ich vermute, diese Nachricht hat es auch bis in die Serie A geschafft und war dann weitere Motivation, dass sie sich gesagt haben, gut, dass, jetzt hauen wir noch mal einen raus. Alex, du hast es ja auch schon angedeutet, also wir haben auch die Copa del Rey in Spanien noch gehabt. Wo haben denn die Finalspiele diesmal und auch das Final Fortuner diesmal stattgefunden? Deswegen habe ich das vorhin so anmoderiert. Da hatten wir doch in der Vergangenheit auch schon Spiele, die in China stattgefunden haben, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Saudi-Arabien glaube ich auch schon mal. Wie war es diesmal?
Saudi-Arabien ist es. War es auch schon letztes Mal. Da hat der spanische Verband einen, ich meine, 3-Jahres-Vertrag abgeschlossen. Und dementsprechend bekommt der Verband ein ganz schönes Sümmchen, ein ziemliches, ein ziemliches Batzen Geld, wie man das hierzulande nennt. Die Rede ist von 40 Millionen pro Jahr, also pro ausgetragenem, pro ausgetragener Supercoppa. Das ist viel Geld. Auch die Vereine bekommen viel Geld. Also nicht nur der Verband sahnt ab, sondern jeder Halbfinalist hat, ich meine, 7 Millionen Antrittsprämie bekommen. Nur fürs Halbfinale. Und dann natürlich, wenn du ins Finale kommst und wenn du dieses gewinnst, gibt es noch mal eine Stange obendrauf. Also ich meine, Real Madrid hat irgendwie 15 Millionen oder so plus minus verdient. Einfach nur durch die beiden Spiele. Das ist jetzt in der Corona-Pandemie auch nicht so schlecht, wo alle Vereine grundsätzlich finanzielle Probleme haben. Aber ja, man kauft das natürlich teuer, aber das wird teuer bezahlt. Man muss nach Saudi-Arabien. Auch nicht unbedingt so cool. Raul Garcia von Athletic Bilbao hat sich da sehr deutlich geäußert und hat auch gesagt, das, was wir alle ja denken, es ist ein spanischer Pokal und er wird nicht auf spanischen Boden ausgetragen. Es geht nur noch ums Geld. Man denkt nicht mehr an die Fans, etc. Da war er sehr ehrlich. Ich weiß nicht, wie das beim Verband ankam, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also Saudi-Arabien, der neue Player. Irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Hendrik, erinnert mich das an die Premier League. Man kommt jetzt auch nicht drauf, welche Verbindung es da gibt. Aber du wolltest ja eigentlich über das Meisterschaftsrennen sprechen und mit dem hat, nachdem was ich so gehört habe, Newcastle immer noch nichts zu tun, obwohl sie doch jetzt so viel Geld haben. Komisch, dass das so lange dauert. Ist das deine Prognose? Geht Newcastle runter?
Es ist halt schwer zu sagen, weil es natürlich so ein bisschen davon abhängt, was jetzt noch passiert in den letzten Tagen des Transfer-Fans. Aber die Mannschaft, das ist halt im Grunde eine Zweitligamannschaft. Auch jetzt seit der Übernahme und seitdem Eddie Hauer, der Trainer, gekommen ist, sind die Ergebnisse nicht besser geworden. Die Transfers, die es jetzt gab, haben mich auch nicht überzeugt. Und es wird extrem eng.
Genau, wir wollten ja eigentlich über die Meisterschaft, die jetzt auf einmal entschieden ist. Ich sehe die Tabelle und über allen thront Manchester City mit 11 Punkten im Vorsprung vor Liverpool. Wenn man es im Kopf nicht mehr gleich ausrechnen kann, ist das ein schlechtes Zeichen für die Spannung im Meisterschaftskampf. Was ist da passiert?
Genau, was ist da passiert? Also eigentlich ist das passiert, was man in den letzten Jahren schon gesehen hat, dass nämlich Manchester City einfach aufgrund des Kaders, den man nun mal hat und sich leisten kann. Manchester City leistet sich keine Aussetzer und keine Einbrüche. Die haben mit 12 Spielen nacheinander gewonnen, trotz teilweise Verletzungen, trotz auch Corona-Fällen. Andere Vereine waren wahrscheinlich stärker betroffen, aber Manchester City hatte Probleme. Pep Guardiola hat ja selbst ausgefallen mit Corona. Und das alles kann Manchester City aber besser wegstecken als die Konkurrenz. Und deswegen dominiert die Liga einfach weiter wie gehabt. Wie gesagt, 12 Siege nacheinander. Davon waren nicht alle immer überzeugend oder auch nicht berauschend. Aber das spricht dann auch noch mal für die Qualität von Manchester City, dass sie gar nicht bei 100 Prozent sein müssen und trotzdem diese Liga dominieren. Es gab am Wochenende ein 1-0 gegen Chelsea durch ein schönes Kevin de Bruyne-Tor. Das hätte auch anders ausgehen können. Aber im Endeffekt bringen sie diese Spiele halt nach Hause und dann haben sie aber trotzdem auch so Spiele drin wie gegen Newcastle 4-0, gegen Leeds 7-0, auch gegen Leicester 6-3, wo sie den Gegner dann einfach an die Wand spielen und abschießen. Und das ist, es wird die vierte Meisterschaft für Manchester City in den letzten fünf Jahren. Es wird die dritte davon sein, wo die Meisterschaft relativ klar auch ausfallen wird oder auch relativ früh schon entschieden war. So wie in dieser eine Saison, wo Liverpool, Manchester City bis zum letzten Spieltag noch auf den Fersen war und es dann aber doch für Manchester City ausging. Und 2020 war natürlich Liverpool Meister, aber ansonsten in den letzten Jahren eigentlich immer City, der Liga davongelaufen und hatte das Meisterschaftsrennen ziemlich früh schon entschieden. So ist es auch jetzt und das ist für die Premier League natürlich nicht unbedingt ein gutes Zeichen, weil die Premier League sich ja immer dafür rühmt, so ausgeglichen zu sein und dass immer mehrere Mannschaften die Chance auf die Meisterschaft haben. Und gerade zum Anfang dieser Saison hatte man ja auch gedacht, Manchester City, Chelsea, Liverpool, die werden bis zum Schluss wirklich, wird es einen Dreikampf in den Titel geben. Und so sah es ja Anfang Dezember auch noch aus. Also da war Chelsea der Ballenführer und die sind dann aber jetzt, genau wie Liverpool, auch in dieser immer extrem intensiven Zeit in England um Weihnachten und um den Jahreswechsel, wo es einfach wahnsinnig viele Spiele gibt. Diese beiden Teams sind zurückgefallen. Also Chelsea mit vielen Verletzungsproblemen, vielen Corona-Fällen auch hat sich sehr viele Unentschieden geleistet. Das ist gar nicht so, dass sie plötzlich ständig verloren hätten, aber die haben sehr oft Unentschieden gespielt. Liverpool hat Unentschieden gegen die Spurs, ein Spiel ist ausgefallen und eine Niederlage gegen Leicester. Und das reicht dann halt bei diesem Manchester City, dass sich halt wirklich keine Schreche erlaubt. Reicht das dann halt, um plötzlich mit elf, bzw. bei Chelsea sind es 13 Punkte hinten dran zu liegen und man da sagen muss, das wird in dieser Saison mit der Meisterschaft nichts mehr und das ist auch nochmal ein Verdienst, wenn man so will, oder ein Zeichen dieser Entwicklung von Manchester City, dass Manchester City komplett die Standards in der Liga verschoben hat, was du halt brauchst, um Meister zu werden. Also Manchester United ist ja in der Folge sind öfter mit um die 80 Punkten Meister geworden. So in Manchester City, wenn du dir die Punktzahlen anguckst, die die Mannschaft erholt, das ist immer im hohen 90er Bereich und da muss man als Verfolger perfekt sein, um überhaupt eine Chance zu haben und das sind weder Chelsea noch Liverpool.
Warum nur habe ich das Gefühl, zu wissen, wie Alexi auf seine Abschlussdiskussion zum Super League kommt.
Übrigens zu dem Thema, wenn ich dazwischengerätschen habe, gab es interessante Artikel, ich glaube in der Irish Times und im Independent, die sich mit diesem Thema, der Vormachtstellung von City, wie übermächtig sie sind, wie sehr sie dem Fan auch den Spaß am Fußball, an der Premier League nehmen, weil sie so emotionslos mechanisch ihre Siege einfahren, weil sie so überlegen sind, weil Pep Guardiola zu perfekt ein Fußball spielt, weil die Spiele zu eindeutig sind, selbst wenn sie nicht ergebnistechnisch eindeutig sind, wie gegen Chelsea, dieses 1-0, aber sie lassen nichts zu, der Gegner hat kaum Chancen und sie spulen das so runter. Ziemlich interessant, diese Thematik, also Pep Guardiola macht den englischen Fußball kaputt, er ist zu gut mit seiner Mannschaft quasi.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall interessantes Thema und gerade in Independent und den Kollegen Miguel Delaney kann man da immer empfehlen, der tolle Sachen zur Premier League generell schreibt, aber auch zu Manchester City und einen sehr guten und kritischen Blick auch drauf hat. Es ist natürlich einerseits Pep Guardiola, der einfach ein guter Trainer ist, das kann man ihm ja nicht vorwerfen, aber natürlich zeigt diese Dominanz von Manchester City auch das Problem, dass du hast, wenn ein Verein nicht von, wie es in der Premier League ja langgegangen gäbe, war einfach nur von Legalen oder Geschäftsmännern besessen, finanziert und geführt wird, sondern de facto von Staaten. Und das ist natürlich im Fall von Manchester City nochmal was anderes, weil da steckt bekanntlich Abu Dhabi hinter und die haben nochmal ganz andere finanzielle Möglichkeiten als das Roman Abramowicz zum Beispiel hat bei Chelsea und...
Aber unterscheidet sich denn das vom Volumen, was da eingesetzt wird, wirklich so krass? Also Abramowicz hatte doch, glaube ich, auch im Zeitraum der ersten zehn Jahre so rund 800 bis 900 Millionen Euro eingesetzt. City liegt jetzt dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie bei 1,2 Milliarden oder so. Ist natürlich ein Unterschied, gebe ich schon zu, aber ist das wirklich die Finanzpower, die da den Unterschied macht? Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, du sagst, wenn man es schafft, finanzielle Kraft mit sportlicher Kompetenz und eine Kladerplanung, die dann funktioniert, zusammenzubringen, dann kommt so eine Dominanz bei raus.
Genau, es ist natürlich so ein bisschen beides, da hast du recht. Aber City hatte ja, als wir bei City eingestiegen sind, die im Grunde eine komplett weiße Leinwand vor sich. Also die haben im Grunde diesen Verein von wirklich tiefgreifend umstrukturiert und neu aufgebaut mit der neuen Akademie, mit dem neuen Trainingszentrum, dann natürlich auch mit der entsprechenden Struktur um Guardiola herum, mit Soriano und Ligarif Stemma, also seinem alten Kompetent aus Barcelona. Und dass man ihm schon diese Struktur so hinstellen konnte und dann auch noch diesen Trainer holt, das ist, glaube ich, eine Sache, die für einen Verein wie Chelsea oder Abramovic nicht möglich ist, anders als es bei Manchester City mit Abu Dhabi eben geht. So, aber ich gebe dir Recht, dass es natürlich nicht nur das eingesetzte Geld ist, sondern auch grundsätzlich die strukturellen Veränderungen, die man in diesem Verein durchgeführt hat.
Alexi, wie ist denn das in der Liga? Du wolltest ja sowieso über PSG sprechen und das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht alle komplett vom Hocker hauen, wenn ich sage, auch PSG wird sehr wahrscheinlich französischer Meister werden. Der Ausrutscher aus dem letzten Jahr, der wurde mehr als wieder wettgemacht. Hier sprechen wir von 11 Punkten Vorsprung vor der neuen zweiten Macht Nizza, über die wir ja dann auch noch reden können. Was sind denn die Gründe dafür, dass PSG so vorweg marschiert in der Liga?
Ja, es ist nicht so schlimm wie die Bundesliga, weil man vergisst immer, in der Liga 1 gab es trotzdem in den letzten zehn Jahren vier verschiedene Meister mit Montpellier, mit Monaco, mit Lille und natürlich immer wieder PSG. Aber Paris hat es nicht mal viermal in Folge geschafft, trotz der Scheiß aus dem Qatar, trotz so vielen namhaften Spieler. Und natürlich ist man jetzt wieder weit davon gezogen, weil man die Lehren gezogen hat, aus der vergangenen Spielzeit, wo man ja hinter Lille Meister wurde, Herr Witze Meister wurde eben, was schon nicht für eine Schande, aber für einen riesen Misserfolg gesorgt hat und für viel Unruhe im Verein. Deswegen hat man auf dem Transfermarkt richtig Gas gegeben mit Messi, mit Ramos, Weinaldum und Co. Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass Paris im nächstes oder übernächstes Jahr wieder nicht Meister wird, weil diese Mannschaft einfach, das ist weder eine Mannschaft, noch ein Verein. Das ist ein Verein, eine Stadt. Und solange diese Menschen an der Macht sind bei Paris Saint-Germain, wird PSG keine Einheit bilden auf dem Platz und insofern sich auch nicht dermaßen fokussieren auf die Liga und dass man vier-, fünf-, sechs-, siebenmal in Folge Meister wird, weil auch andere Mannschaften über sich hinaus wachsen, wie man mit ihnen sehen konnte in der vergangenen Saison. Und wir werden nachher über Niza sprechen. Die kommen schon langsam, weil die haben auch unheimlich viel Geld und dazu Potenzial und vielleicht mehr Hirn bei den ganz, bei den Chefs, bei den Entscheidern. Und auch Monaco wird wieder spätestens nächstes Saison ein Wort um die Meisterschaft mitreden, weil die wollen und die haben auch finanzielle Mittel und die haben glaube ich vom Konzept her bessere Ideen als Paris Saint-Germain, die nur die klangvollsten Namen addieren wollen, ohne zu wissen, dass alle gar nicht miteinander spielen wollen.
Das scheint ja so der größte Unterschied zu sein. Also ich habe mir mal die Transfersalden laut transfermarkt.de für die letzten zehn Jahre rausgeholt, eben liegenübergreifend. Da hat das größte Minus gemacht, tatsächlich Manchester United mit über einer Milliarde Euro im Saldo-Ausgaben. Manchester City aber auch mit über einer Milliarde, nur wenige Millionen dahinter. Und dann kommt schon PSG mit einem Saldo von minus 940 Millionen Euro. Es gibt da eine große Lücke zu weiteren Vereinen wie Arsenal und Barca. Das heißt, da scheinen wir tatsächlich einen interessanten Unterschied zu haben. Die Champions League gewonnen haben jetzt ja aber beide Mannschaften nicht. Also sowohl Manchester City als auch PSG. Und das scheint ja auch der Fokus zu sein, den Paris hatte. Es ist jetzt auch keine Neuigkeit. Was macht denn das mit der Liga deiner Meinung nach? Du wolltest ja sowieso auch in so ein Super League-Thema reingehen. Da können wir ja gerne mal jetzt mit loslegen.
Ja, ich meine, für die PSG-Stars ist es schon immer wieder schwierig, sich auf die Liga 1 zu konzentrieren bzw. sich für die Liga 1 zu motivieren. Das hat man letzte Saison gesehen oder vor fünf Jahren als Monaco-Meister wurde und in einem richtigen Lauf war. Paris Saint-Germain zählt eigentlich nur die Monate. Februar, März und vielleicht sogar April, wenn man über das Achtelfinale hinauskommt, was jahrelang, ihr wisst ja, nicht der Fall war. Damals, zum Beispiel 1 zu 6 in Barcelona, vor vier Jahren mittlerweile. Und wenn man jetzt gegen Real ausschaltet, im März, wo man nicht fest ausgehe, Stand heute, dann ist die Saison eh vorbei. Dann wird es eh nur noch Freundschaftsspiele für die Spieler geben in der Liga 1, vielleicht noch der Pokal nebenbei, aber es wird darum gehen, eine noch schlagkräftigere Mannschaft für die kommende Saison zusammen zu bauen oder zu basteln, damit man der Champions-League endlich mal ganz weiterkommt. Aber wir haben ja diese Saison, bzw. am Ende des Jahres die WM in Katar, also bei den Chefs von PSG und wenn man in dieser Saison bereits im Achtelfinale ausscheidet, dann wird es ein richtiges Erdbeben geben in der französischen Hauptstadt und da bin ich gespannt, was dann passiert. Es gibt auch immer wieder Gerüchte, vielleicht steigen dann die Scheiß aus, nicht vor der WM, das ist ja völlig ausgeschlossen, aber vielleicht am 25. Dezember, also zwei, drei Tage nach dem Endspiel bei der WM und für PSG und die Entscheider zählt einfach nur diese europäischen Spiele und für die, auch wenn das El Khalifi, weil er jetzt Präsident des SCA ist, nicht offiziell sagt, aber er träumt auch nur noch von der Super League. Er ist auch nur im Stadion in der Champions League oder in der Liga gegen die Großen, also Monaco macht sehr jung, aber ansonsten ist er auch nicht zu sehen, weder zu Hause noch auswärts und deswegen ist Paris das beste Beispiel, dass das Super League kommen muss. Aber man sieht es ja auch in Deutschland. Die Bundesliga ist langweilig seit zehn Jahren, es wird auch nicht besser und ich glaube schon, dass die Bayern sich lieber auf Bayern gegen Real freuen als Bayern gegen Freiburg.
Das habe ich jetzt zum ersten Mal, dass es da Gerüchte gibt, dass Katar sogar aussteigen könnte bei PSG. Ist das konkreter oder sprechen wir da jetzt wirklich einfach noch von höheren Sagen?
Das ist überhaupt nicht konkret, aber warum sind die scheiß eingestiegen? Es gab ja 2011, ja es gab einfach einen Kompromiss mit dem damaligen Staatspräsidenten Nicolas Sarkozy, großer PSG-Anhänger und der wollte, dass Paris eine große Nummer in Europa wird. Damals war dieser Verein sowohl sportlich als auch wirtschaftlich kurz vor dem Banroth. Man war fast in der zweiten Liga, muss man sich vorstellen. Und dann hat er die Möglichkeit gesehen mit Qatar und das war halt das Kompromiss. Die Scheiß steigen ein bei PSG mit dem Versprechen, ganz viel Geld zu investieren, ganz große Spieler zu verpflichten und damit konkurrenzfähig zu sein in der Champions League, um den Hengelport zu holen. Und auf der anderen Seite werden, oder wird Qatar, ganz viel in Paris oder in Frankreich auch investieren können und sich dadurch viel mehr ins Rampenlicht spielen können, bzw. bekannter machen. In Hylwig natürlich auf die WM. Und die WM in diesem Jahr ist ja das ganz große Ziel der Scheiß. Und es ist halt die Frage, was passiert danach eigentlich? Da sind wir sehr gespannt, ob die bleiben. Vielleicht der ganz große Chef, Al Thamine, der in Doha wohnt und ein, zwei Mal im Jahr nach Paris kommt. Was macht der, wenn Paris wieder gegen Real Sanger und Klanglos ausscheidet im Februar? Irgendwann ist auch die Geduld vorbei und vielleicht schaut er sich nach einem neuen Verein. Das ist nicht konkret, aber nicht auszuschließen bei diesen Leuten.
Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt auf die Diskussion. Ich frage einfach in die Runde und wer möchte, darf als erstes reinspringen. Stimmt dir da Alexi zu, wenn er sagt, die Super League muss und wird kommen?
Muss nicht, aber wird bestimmt.
Okay.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage, was man möchte und vielleicht noch ein bisschen, was man als Fan möchte und auch als Interessierter möchte. Ein Großteil der Leute, die sich wirklich so interessieren möchten, diese Super League nicht. Zumindest ist das so unsere Wahrnehmung in unserem Kosmos. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, das ist ein bisschen unvermeidbar, weil, das habe ich auch schon besprochen, die Tendenzen gehen dahin, dass die Ligen immer langweiliger werden, zumindest an der Spitze, weil es halt diese dominanten Teams gibt und weil natürlich diese großen Vereine auch sagen, das große Geld verdient man halt im Zweifel mit dieser Super League. Also das ist ja jetzt schon mit dem internationalen Wettbewerb und der Champions League. Und die Champions League, wie sie künftig sein wird, ist ja schon ein Kompromiss der UEFA, um halt so ein bisschen diese Super League-Rebellen zu beschwichtigen. Aber ich glaube, die Entwicklung geht ja ganz klar in die Richtung. Und ist dann die Frage, ob das gut ist und was das auch für die nationalen Wettbewerbe heißt. Also ob dann diese Vereine überhaupt nicht mehr in den nationalen Ligen teilnehmen. Die Idee bei dieser Super League jetzt im Frühjahr war ja, dass sie weiterhin noch in den nationalen Ligen spielen. Dann ist die Frage, ob das dann noch der Fall sein wird und welche Bedeutung die in den nationalen Ligen haben. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass diese Super League, die ist jetzt im Frühjahr, die haben früher gelauncht wurde. Das war ein Testballon, um also ein bisschen die Stimmung auszutesten. Und jetzt haben, glaube ich, viele vor allen Dingen gesehen, wie man es idealerweise besser macht. Und wenn man das nächste Mal so einen Versuch startet, habe ich das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen unvermeidlich ist, dass es in diese Richtung geht.
Wenn ich kurz reingretschen darf, es sind in Frankreich jetzt schon mal Pläne, wenn jetzt Super League kommt. Also es ist schon das Gerücht, 2024 spätestens. Und dann würde man die Ligue 1 zum Beispiel, und das ist auch vielleicht ein Thema für die anderen Top-Ligen, die Ligue 1 von 20 auf 16 Mannschaften reduzieren, damit man mehr Freiräume hat für den gesamten Spielplan. Und das ist auch natürlich die Frage, wie die Ligue 1 oder die Meisterschaft unter der Woche ausgetragen, und die Champions League am Wochenende oder umgekehrt. Also da gibt es noch viele Fragezeichen, aber auch diese Reform ist nicht auszuschließen.
Und von wem kommen diese Pläne? Hat es der Verband direkt schon mal proaktiv sich überlegt?
Das sind halt die Vereine, die pro Super League sind. Ja, die Spanier, Real und Barca. Dazu glaube ich Juve. Und ich habe da keine Infos, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass diese Pläne, die es schon länger gibt, insbesondere geführt von Florentino Perez, dass da auch ein El Calafi und ein Rummenigge beziehungsweise Miklavele Olivakani involviert sind. Also das geht auch nicht unter diese Leute. Und wenn die nicht Super League heißt, dann heißt die vielleicht Geile Liga oder sowas in der Richtung, aber ein Synonym für, ja, jetzt machen wir eine Liga unter uns. Mit vielleicht, und das wäre natürlich schade und eigentlich nicht im Sinne des Fußballs, aber ohne Auf- und Abstieg. Aber das sind wie gesagt Pläne, Ideen. Aber ich glaube, da werden wir mehr wissen in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten. Aber da wird sich was bewegen, das ist klar.
Ich glaube, wir müssen unbedingt noch die Meinung von Alex und Christian abholen. Alex, du darfst mal anfangen, denn mit Florentino Perez und ja auch Barca. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wer da jetzt dann der entscheidende Mann aktuell ist. Zu viele Namen zuletzt gelesen rund um Barca. Kommen ja zwei der Initiatoren, die immer noch ja auch in offenem Rechtsstreit mit der UEFA stehen aus Spanien. Wie würdest du denn die ganze Situation einschätzen und gibt es denn da auch Entwicklungen, die wir vielleicht hier in Deutschland gar nicht mitbekommen?
Initiatoren und Triebfedern sind Perez von Real Madrid und Agneli von Juventus. Und Barca schließt sich so ein bisschen, warum auch immer, dem Kollegen Perez an. Ich glaube, das Warum ist recht klar, weil sie natürlich die Geldpötte sehen, spüren können und dringend gebrauchen können, angesichts der Milliardenschulden. Und das ist, glaube ich, so die Triebfeder. Ja, das ist aus irgendeinem Grund Florentino Perez Wunsch, Traum, großes Projekt. Ich persönlich halte da nicht so viel davon. Ich wäre aber auch gespannt, wenn sich da in nächster Zeit diesbezüglich was entwickeln würde. Denn sie wurde ja abgestraft. Der Backlash war ja ziemlich krass für Perez und Co. Die Engländer alle ausgestiegen, sodass nur noch Juve, Real und Barca übrig blieben. Und eine 3-Mann-Super League, die funktioniert nicht so wirklich. Und plus gibt es die Champions-League-Reformen in, ich meine, 2024 wird es jetzt umgesetzt. Wo es ja eh mehr in Richtung Super Champions League geht, um es mal so zu formulieren. Von daher würde es mich wundern, wenn jetzt demnächst quasi erneut neue Super League-Pläne publik werden würden.
Ja, wie angesprochen, klar, Anjeli ist ein ganz starker Triebfeder auch. Da muss man ja auch bei Juve erklären. Anjeli war ja auch der, der vor zehn Jahren gekommen ist, der Juve auch so zur Weltmarke machen wollte. Das wäre auch der Christiano-Ronaldo-Transfer, also so nochmal den Verein nochmal auf die ganz große Bühne bringen. Juve ist ja auch weiterhin, als es diese Absagen gab, zwischen den Seilen, hat Juve auch gar nicht versteckt, zu verheimlichen, zu sagen, wir glauben immer noch daran. Also wir sind immer noch fest davon überzeugt, dass das System reformiert werden muss. Also im Moment hört man von Juve relativ wenig, weil sie auch selber mehr als genug Probleme haben, aber dass Juve da weiterhin ganz ganz sicher in diese Richtung, hinter den Kulissen auch mit anschieben wird, steht außer Frage. Ich bin aber auch gespannt, wieviel sie da wirklich auf Italien betrachtet Mitstreiter finden, denn ja, wie gesagt, Juve ist, die Serie ist, finde ich im Moment ja auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass selbst jemand, der eine Liga über fast ein komplettes Jahrzehnt dominiert, wenn der dann plötzlich Fehler macht, und da hat Juve eben zuletzt Fehler gemacht, dass dann andere durchaus die Chance haben, da in diese Lücke hereinstoßen zu können. Und wir kommen ja später auch nochmal drauf. Klar scheint Inter da momentan sehr solide dazu stehen, gar keine Frage, aber ich finde, Milan ist im Moment auch gar nicht so weit weg. Davon entfernt Napoli, Atalanta, selbst Juve hat sich jetzt sportlich zumindest wieder etwas gefangen. Also ich finde, die Serie A gibt eigentlich im Moment auch genügend Argumente her, dass man durchaus auch wieder sich sozusagen aus dem eigenen Prozess heraus sich vielleicht auch mehr für Spannung sorgen kann. Klar ist, du brauchst dann, wie im Fall von Juve im Moment, wenn da eine große Player da war, dann musst du ja auch Fehler machen, gar keine Frage. In Italien war das der Fall und dementsprechend kommt da irgendwie auch so ein bisschen frische neue Luft rein. Das wäre jetzt eben dann die Frage gewesen, die ich auch mit den anderen noch hätte besprechen wollen. Bei Italien ist es gerade einfach, da ist es gerade spannend. Inter 50 Punkte, Milan 48, Napoli 46. Das heißt, da haben wir einen Dreikampf, wenn man so möchte, auch wenn Inter da natürlich klare Vorteile hat. Alex, in La Liga war es ja immer ein Duell und dann wurde es irgendwann ein Dreikampf. Es hat sich was verändert in dieser Saison, was Barca angeht. Die sind irgendwie rausgefallen. Ist denn die Liga so langweilig, dass du sagst, eigentlich braucht es das auch?
Dass es eine Super League braucht, meinst du? Nein, nein, nein, da würde ich komplett dagegen gehen. Braucht es nicht. Was es braucht, ist, dass sich die Finanzen von Barca ein bisschen legen. Und da sieht es ja gut danach aus. Sprich, dass Barca einfach ein bisschen besser wird, dann wäre das Ganze schon spannend. Was es braucht, ist, dass Atletico Madrid einfach besser Fußball spielt. Den Kader dafür hätten sie, aber sie bekommen es einfach nicht hin. Sie sind aktuell 16 Punkte, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hinter Real Madrid. Das ist enorm. Das ist der letztjährige Meister und es sind 20 Spieltage rum. Das war so nicht vorherzusehen. Die Gründe sind schwer zu erklären, aber im Endeffekt, sie hätten den Kader. Sie haben die Klasse. Es braucht einfach mehr Konstanz von den beiden Kontrahenten von Real Madrid. Sevilla kann kaum viel konstanter spielen. Die sind ja schon auf fünf Punkte dran. Beziehungsweise bei einem Spiel weniger wären es ja dann sogar zwei Punkte womöglich nur. Also so viel braucht es da eigentlich nicht, damit die Liga spannender ist. Und natürlich den einen oder anderen Ausrutscher von Real Madrid, okay, der könnte auch nicht schaden. Aber ich würde nicht so weit gehen, dass ich sage, es bräuchte eine Super League, damit endlich wieder Spannung ist.
So und wie ist es dann in der Premier League, Hendrik? Das war ja unser Ausgangspunkt so ein bisschen.
Also du meinst, ob ich meine, dass die Premier League die Super League braucht?
Ja, also ob die ist es ein Problem, das sind natürlich jetzt die sehr deutsche Perspektive. Aber in Deutschland würde ich sagen, es ist ein Problem, dass Bayern immer gewinnt und das ist nach außen hin und nach innen hin nicht gut für eine Liga. Jetzt deutet sich das ja in der Premier League im Grunde zum ersten Mal seit der Dominanz von Manchester United glaube ich an und vielleicht dann noch in den 80ern. Liverpool hatte mal endlich einen Run, dass man quasi so viele Meisterschaften in Folge holen konnte. Ist es auch ein Problem für die Premier League? Also auch ein quasi so schweres Problem, dass man sagt, da muss sich wirklich was verändern, was vielleicht die Diskussion dann, das heißt dann nicht Super League, sondern es wird anders heißen, aber das, was die Diskussion noch mal anders befeuert.
Ich glaube nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Also es ist ein Problem natürlich diese Dominanz von Manchester City, zumal sie halt ja auch nicht nur darin begründet ist, dass Manchester City in den vergangenen Jahren und Jahrzehnten so großartige Arbeit gemacht hat, sondern dass da einfach der entsprechende Geldgeber hintersteht. Von daher ist der Vergleich mit Liverpool in den 80ern und Manchester United danach auch ein bisschen schwierig, weil es andere Ausgangssituationen sind. Aber ich glaube und wie gesagt, das wird auch hier entsprechend reflektiert. Also viele Leute und viele Medien wird es auch kritisch besprochen, dass Manchester City eben diese Dominanz hat. Trotzdem war ja auch hier der Backlash gegen die Super League extrem. Und in England ist man extrem stolz auf diese Football Pyramid, also auf dieses Ligensystem und den Abstieg und dass jeder gegen jeden auch mal verlieren kann und so weiter und so fort. Das ist zwar oft nur in der Theorie dann wirklich existent, aber die Engländer wollen schon die Premier League behalten und die Engländer wollen schon, dass Manchester City auch zu Burnley und Norwich und Brighton muss. Von daher ist jetzt hier die Stimmung nicht so, dass die Leute sagen würden, Manchester City sollen in die Super League gehen und dann haben wir wieder eine spannende Liga. Also ganz im Gegenteil, zumal es ja auch gerade in England die Diskussion und die Super League und die extreme Empörung auch ein Stück weit scheinheilig war, wenn man sich zurück erinnert. Die Premier League ist ja 1992 gegründet worden als Abspaltung der reichsten Clubs, die gesagt haben, wir wollen im Grunde die Vermarktungen und die Rechte und so weiter selbst verkaufen und wollen nicht mehr mit der alten Football League zusammen oder nicht mehr unter dem Schirm der alten Football League spielen, sondern wollen halt unsere eigene Liga haben, also die Premier League ist ja im Grunde auch eine Super League schon. Von daher fand ich es ein bisschen schwierig, mit welcher moralischen Empörtheit hier auch diese Super League diskutiert wurde im Frühjahr. Aber ich glaube insgesamt sind die Engländer halt schon stolz auf die Premier League und mögen die Premier League gern und es ist ja ein bisschen Licht am Horizont zu sehen, wenn dann Pep Guardiola in zwei Jahren nach der nächsten Saison möglicherweise Manchester City verlässt. Also muss man natürlich mal schauen, was das dann bedeutet. Die Strukturen bei Manchester City ja weiterhin auch vorhanden sind, um diese Liga zu dominieren. Aber ich würde jetzt auch davon absehen zu sagen, dass der Meisterschaftskampf in der Premier League auf Jahrzehnte verloren ist. Also das glaube ich nicht weiter.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ein großes Überthema gehabt. Dann lass mal wieder zum konkreten Tagesgeschäft zu kommen. Hendrik, wenn du gerade schon eh schon mit dran bist, also die Stimmung in der Premier League ist trotz der Dominanz von City dann noch halbwegs entspannt. Wie ist denn die Stimmung beim FC Everton?
Ja, gar nicht so entspannt und das ja auch schon länger. Also Everton ist, muss man vielleicht ein bisschen weiter ausholen, ist ja ein großer Verein. Eigentlich war oft Meister, ist nach wie vor der Verein mit den viert meisten Meistertiteln in England. Hat auch eine große Fangemeinde in Liverpool. Schönes altes Stadion plant, ein schönes neues Stadion, auch mitten in den Doglands von Liverpool. Ist also eigentlich ein großer Club mit auch ziemlich großen Ambitionen und scheitert aber an diesen Ambitionen seit Jahren immer wieder tragisch. Und jetzt ist Rafa Benitez der Trainer, der vor der Saison kam, das jüngste Opfer bei Everton. Er hatte bei dem Verein nie so wirklich eine Chance oder zumindest bei der Fangemeinde des Clubs, weil er unbekanntlich ja auch lange beim FC Liverpool war. Dem großen Rivalen, zehn Minuten vom Goodison Park entfernt, mit Liverpool ja auch Champions League-Sieger geworden ist in diesem Wahnsinnsfinale von 2005, so eine extreme emotionale Verbindung auch zum FC Liverpool hat. Das ist natürlich den Everton-Fans schwer vermittelbar gewesen.
Was haben die sich denn dabei gedacht, Benitez als Trainer zu holen? Jenseits von, dass er natürlich eine sportliche Kompetenz hat. Aber war das nicht absehbar, dass beim ersten, dass es schlecht läuft, es da ein ganz eisiger Wind ihm um die Nase weht?
Ja, das war absehbar. Und es gibt dabei in diesem Verein, vor allem bei dem Besitzer, Fahad Moschiri, der vor fünf Jahren eingestiegen ist, vor sechs Jahren eingestiegen ist, gibt es dieses Bedürfnis, dass Everton auch große Namen verpflichtet. Also wir hatten ja Ancelotti davor schon, gab es auch Spieler wie Hammes zum Beispiel. Also es gibt ein gewisses Bedürfnis nach großen Namen. Und da hat Rafa Benitez natürlich reingepasst. Aber das ist vollkommen konzeptlos. Abgesehen davon gibt es keine richtige Idee, wie man diesen Verein langfristig wieder dahin bringen möchte, wo er mal war. Und das sieht man auch ganz gut daran, dass in den letzten Wochen bei Everton verschiedene Menschen in Führungspositionen den Verein verlassen haben. Also der Director of Football ist gegangen, der Vereinsarzt ist gegangen, die Chefs des Scouting und des Recruitments sind gegangen und wurden mehr oder weniger Benetis geopfert, weil der Verein sich hinter Benetis gestellt hat. Und jetzt ist Benetis halt selbst auch weg. Man hat halt Benetis entlassen und das zeigt so ein bisschen, dass es glaube ich bei Everton in der Führungsetage nicht so eine richtige langfristige Planung gibt, wie man es hinbekommen will, den Verein eben wieder zu alter Größe zu führen. Und genau wie du sagst, es war absehbar, dass sobald es die erste Krise gibt, dass es für Benetis extrem rau werden würde und das hat sich jetzt auch gezeigt. Der Saisonstart war noch ganz okay, obwohl man andererseits in den Jahren davor kaum Geld ausgeben konnte. Also Everton musste sehr sparsam sein in diesem Sommer und dafür war der Saisonstart echt gut, aber jetzt die letzten Monate waren dramatisch. Und dann gab es zum Wochenende in Niederlage gegen Norwich. Erinnern sich ja auch noch viele daran. Norwich damals mit Daniel Fahke im Grunde galt schon als sichere Absteiger und plötzlich sich mit diesem Sieg gegen Everton vom Tabellenende gelöst. Aber gegen Norwich darf man natürlich nicht verlieren in dieser Situation. Das hat dann im Endeffekt Benetest den Job gekostet, aber das war, wie du halt schon sagst, von vorn an absehbar, dass das nicht gut enden wird.
Wir haben für dich in der Premier League noch eine besondere Situation, nämlich viele wegen Corona-Fällen verschobene Spiele. Da wurde jetzt auch durchaus schon kontrovers darüber diskutiert, weil es jetzt unter anderem so war, korrigiere mich, wenn ich es mir falsch gemerkt habe, aber Arsenal hatte jetzt zum Beispiel nur in Anführungszeichen einen infizierten Spieler. Ich will jetzt nicht die Infektion selber kleinreden, aber die Zahl ist natürlich wesentlich geringer und hat dennoch dann schon danach verlangt, dass ein Spiel verschoben werden würde. Und insgesamt, also Everton zum Beispiel hat eben auch drei Partien, die müssen noch gespielt werden. Die ganze Tabelle ist so ein bisschen schief. Da gibt es Mannschaften, die haben 18 Spiele gespielt. Tottenham zum Beispiel, Leicester zum Beispiel. Es gibt Mannschaften, die haben 22 Spiele gespielt. City zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube, Burnley hat vier Nachholspiele noch in der Hinterhand.
17, genau. Richtig, 17 Spiele hat Burnley erst. Gibt es einen besonderen Grund dafür, dass die Premier League ganz anders betrifft, als viele der anderen europäischen Ligen?
Na ja, ich glaube, es ist erst einmal darin begründet, dass England oder UK generell in den letzten Wochen ganz anders betroffen war, als das europäische Festland. Also Omikron war hier in den Wochen um Weihnachten, also zwei Wochen davor, eine Woche danach, extrem. Sowohl in der Bevölkerung, als auch hier im Grunde keine Restriktion mehr gibt. Und dementsprechend war natürlich auch die Fälle in der Premier League hoch, Fußballspieler und halt auch nur Menschen. Also ich glaube, das ist erst einmal darin begründet, dass England generell stark betroffen war und dann hast du angesprochen, dieses Spiel zum Beispiel von Arsenal, was jetzt verschoben wurde gegen die Spurs, das hat in der Tat für große Diskussionen gesorgt, weil es eine Corona-Infektion gab und die Spurs auch extrem, es gab ein Statement rausgegeben, da hieß es, es sei extrem überrascht, dass dieser Antrag auf die Verschiebung des Spiels, dass der Durchgang ist und extrem überrascht in solchen Kommuniqués heißt ja meistens extrem verärgert. Genau und das geht im Grunde aber auch auf eine Regel zusammen, auf eine Regel zurück, die die Premier League selbst beschlossen hat, nämlich dass die Vereine 13 einsatzfähige Feldspieler haben müssen und wenn sie die nicht haben, dann können sie die Verlegung der Spiele beantragen und Arsene hat jetzt zwar nur ein Corona-Fall, aber es gab mehrere Verletzte, das sind mindestens drei Spieler beim Afrika Cup und da kommt man dann plötzlich doch schon auf eine ganze Menge Ausfälle und da hat Arsene gesagt, passend sind wir ganz gut in Kram, beantragen wir mal die Verschiebung dieses Spiels. Das ist natürlich irgendwie eine Farce, aber es ist halt auch innerhalb der Regeln, die die Premier League sich selbst auferlegt hat. Die Frage ist natürlich, das ist auch die moralische Frage, sollte man alles, was die Regeln theoretisch hergeben, auch nutzen, wenn man es vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt möchte. Weil die Premier League hat mal zum Beispiel auch Akademien, sehr teure Akademien, wo man dann auch sagen könnte, dann lass doch die Spieler spielen, setz die Spieler auf die Bank. Es gab das Beispiel von Leeds United, die haben auch extrem viele Verletzte. Im Moment, die hatten am Wochenende eine Bank, da saßen im Grunde nur ein Probisspieler auf der Bank, die restlichen Spieler waren Spieler aus der Akademie. Da saßen 15-Jährige auf der Bank, die haben trotzdem West Ham geschlagen. Es geht halt schon, wenn man es möchte. Man sieht es aber auch bei einigen Vereinen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel bei Arsenal, dass man diese Regeln aber auch im eigenen Interesse ausnutzen kann und sagen kann, das Spiel passt uns gerade nicht so richtig, dann möchten wir es noch nicht spielen.
20 Spiele wurden jetzt inklusive dieser Partie zwischen Tottenheim und Arsenal verschoben. Es ist genau der Unterschied zu der Regelung hier in der DFL, in der Bundesliga, dass Verletzte nicht mitzellen zum Kontingent. Das wirkt sich dann ganz anders aus bei der Premier League. Dann haben wir noch den Blick nach Frankreich. Da haben wir eine neue Macht, Alexi. Die neue Macht, Nizza. Das hat sich schon ein bisschen angedeutet. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass Nizza hier schon häufiger erwähnt wurde. Auch so ein bisschen als der Tipp zum Sehen. Du hast uns gesagt, Nizza wird in den nächsten 3, 4 Jahren in der Champions League auch mit dabei sein. Das war damals dein Tipp. Das war in der Sendung im Oktober schon der Fall. Was hat sich denn jetzt noch getan, dass du jetzt schon sagst, zweite Macht im französischen Fußball?
Jetzt sage ich sogar, nächste Saison spielen die schon in der Champions League. Und zwar nicht nur, weil diese Mannschaft relativ konstant ist, solide zweiter ist, aber die haben natürlich auch den Meistertrainer in ihren Reihen mit Christoph Galtier, der ja Lille zum Meistertitel geführt hat, vor einem halben Jahr, aber vor allem mit dem Wechsel mit dem Eigentümer Ineos, also einer der reichsten Menschen der Welt, der Engländer, der auch für positive Schlagzeilen gesorgt hat, in anderen Sportarten, in der Formel 1 zum Beispiel, aber auch er hat andere Vereine gekauft, mit Lausanne Sport, jetzt ist er dabei, einen portugiesischen Verein zu kaufen. Und er hat ganz klar das Ziel, Niza ganz weit nach Europa zu bringen. Und zwar nicht so blind wie die Pariser, sondern dann richtig sukzessive, mit viel Geduld, mit vielen Ideen, mit einem klaren Konzept. Die Basis natürlich mit diesem Trainer, der, ruft man Niza, lange bleibt, weil er für diesen Aufbruchstimmung sorgen kann. Und jetzt hat man sich klug verstärkt im Sommer, mit Spielern wie Kleubert, der ein bisschen konstanter ist als in Leipzig oder bei der RS Rom. Natürlich auch mit Dolberg, der schon länger da ist. Du hast natürlich auch Dante als Abwehrchef, knapp 40, aber immer noch so konkurrenzfähig und topfit. Und man hat schon das Gefühl, dass diese Mannschaft am stabilsten ist. Natürlich mit dem Vorteil, man ist in dieser Saison nicht im Europapokal dabei. Man hat auch einen gewissen Fanpotenzial. Es ist ein Traditionsverein mit einer großen Geschichte. Ein Top-Stadion, die Allianz Riviera. Deswegen hat man schon das Gefühl, dass diese Mannschaft sehr weit kommen kann. Und wenn man in der Champions League kommt, das ist anders als bei Lille, wo man viele junge Spieler für wenig Geld kauft und dann wieder für viel Geld verkauft, wie zum Beispiel Leipzig. Das ist in Niza anders. Sollte Niza tatsächlich zum ersten Mal im kommenden Sommer in der Champions League dabei sein, dann wird diese Mannschaft sich auch richtig verstärken. Jetzt nicht mit Messi und Ramos, aber schon mit interessanten Namen, die zur Philosophie passen von Galtier und von Niza und die damit dann nicht nur in der Champions League ein Wort mitreden wollen, sondern auch in der Meisterschaft weiterhin Paris Saint-Germain-Pauli bieten möchte.
Und Ineos ist ein Chemiekonzern, aber dahinter steht quasi eine einzelne Person, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Jim Radcliffe ist der Oberboss, der aber nicht oft in Niza ist, er kommt ab und zu, aber sein Bruder ist eher die seine rechte Hand, aber auch in Niza, hat er das sagen. Und dann hat er Leute installiert, die schon länger im Verein waren, mit Präsident Jean-Pierre Rivere und dem Sportdirektor Julien Fournier, zwei Menschen, die schon da waren, als Lucien Fafon, der Trainer von Niza, war vor vier, fünf Jahren damals auch Champions-League-Qualifikation bestritten, gegen Ajax weitergekommen, ich glaube an Neapel gescheitert. Auf jeden Fall, man sieht ein klares Konzept, wie gesagt, und Ineos ist nach Niza gekommen, nicht unbedingt um die Champions-League zu gewinnen, aber damit Niza eigentlich mal ein Potenzial ausschöpft, sportlich, auch von den Fans her, finanziell, aber auch, um Paris Saint-Germain richtig Konkurrenz zu bieten und das ist natürlich für die Ligue 1, wenn es klappt, eine gute Nachricht.
Champions-League, da denke ich an Bruno Labbadia, da bin ich beim FC Genoa. Das hatte Christian jetzt überrascht. Keine Ahnung, wie du mich damit überraschen kannst. Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Neuer Trainer in der Serie, wie ist das zustande gekommen? Ja, es ist noch nicht offiziell, aber es scheint sich anzudeuten. Genoa hatten wir ja auch schon öfters. Da gab es den Eigentümerwechsel auch vor einigen Monaten. Da war ja Preziosi, einer, der ewig schon dabei war. Jetzt ist es eine neue Investorengruppe. Johannes Spors, ehemaliger Chefscout von Hoffenheim, Hamburg, Leipzig. Er ist jetzt der neue Sportdirektor, auch seit ein paar Wochen. Wie schon in den letzten Jahren auch, ist Genua weiterhin immer ein Kandidat für ganz hinten. Jetzt hat es nicht nur Balardini in der Saison erwischt, sondern jetzt auch Herrn Chefchenko, der nicht lange da war, aber wenig auf die Reihe bekommen hat, was wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur an ihm liegt, sondern auch an dem Material, was da ist. Jetzt darf Herr Labadier eine Truppe übernehmen, die in 20 Spielen ein Spiel bisher gewonnen hat. Wo wieder ein großes Kommen und Gehen ist. Da geistern jetzt auch viele Namen, einige auch mit Bundesliga-Bezug durch die Gegend, weil logischerweise auch Johannes Sporster gute Kontakte hat. Aber wie sind ihr denn auf Johannes Sporster gekommen? Ja gut, der hat sich bei Viteis Arnheim eben einen sehr guten Namen gemacht, hat die letztes Jahr ins Pokalfinale geführt, also nicht als Trainer, aber als Sportdirektor, war sogar auch mal interimsmäßig ein, zwei Spiele als Trainer auf der Bank und hat damit sehr, sehr wenig Geld sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Und eben durch diese neue Ausrichtung, durch die neue Eigentümergruppe, auch bis in dieser internationalere Blick, ist es so weit gekommen und jetzt hoffen sie in Genua, dass diese Kontakte von Sporstar eben auch ihnen zugutekommen. Es gibt auch Namen wie Amiri, zum Beispiel von Leverkusen, den ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt mit FC Genua in Verbindung gebracht hätte, sind jetzt im Raum. Ich bin da auch gespannt, was jetzt bis Ende Januar passiert, aber Fakt ist, Genua hat wirklich jetzt schon ein massives Problem, haben einen relativ großen Rückstand auch schon auf die, ja, sag ich mal, rettenden Plätze. Also das wird alles andere als eine leichte Aufgabe für Bruno Labbadia.
Wenn ich dazwischen grätschen darf, ich war gerade auf Twitter und laut Romano ist Labbadia doch nicht zu Genua oder wechselt doch nicht zu Genua. Ist die Gespräche wohl doch abgebrochen?
Genau, also mein Stand da eben war vorhin noch, dass sie halt noch in Austausch sind. Wenn es jetzt doch nichts wird, dann vielleicht, es hieß, dass es auch noch um finanzielle Konditionen geht. Ich bin mal gespannt oder vielleicht auch, wie gesagt, die Ausgangslage sportlich ist wirklich alles andere als einfach. Also Genua darf man nicht vergessen, ist der älteste Club auch in Italien. Also wirklich ein Club mit wahnsinniger Strahlkraft, auch mit wahnsinniger Tradition einfach. Ich glaube, wenn du der Trainer wärst, mit dem die dann runtergehen oder du daran beteiligt bist, dann wäre das jetzt sicherlich auch nicht unbedingt was, was man sich gern in sein Büchlein schreiben lässt. Gut, dann wird es halt eben nicht brullar bei dir. Sehr gut, dass du da...
Ob das jetzt stimmt, was der Kollege Romano da tweetet?
Also das wäre mir völlig neu, dass der nicht doppelt abgesicherte, super kalte Transfersnurs verbreiten würde. Also das würde mich doch sehr überraschen. So ein zurückhaltender Journalist. Okay, gut, das ist der FC Genoa. Wir haben ja auch einen Trainerwechsel gehabt in der Ligue 1, Alexi. Erzähl uns mal, wie kam es denn jetzt dazu, dass Niko Kovac bei Monaco entlassen wurde?
Ja, es gibt reichlich Gründe, muss man sagen. Der Zeitpunkt war schon mal ungünstig. Das war kurz vor Silvester. Monaco und die Franzosen waren schon in der Winterpause seit zehn Tagen. An dem Tag, an dem der Trainingsauftakt stattfand, hat Niko Kovac erfahren, dass er den Verein verlassen muss. Ursprünglich kam es zum Krachen mit dem Sportdirektor Paul Mitchell, der ihn ursprünglich nach Monaco geholt hat vor eineinhalb Jahren. Beide haben gewisse Spannungen gehabt in ihrem Verhältnis. Sie haben angefangen mit der Verpflichtung von einem Performance-Trainer, der den Kovac gar nicht haben wollte. Aber Mitchell hat ihn durchgesetzt. Kovac wollte aber mehr Macht haben, mehr Freiheit. Das war schon ein bisschen das Problem für ihn in München. Das wurde in Monaco wiederholt und das wollte er unbedingt vermeiden. Dann waren die Ergebnisse in der Hinrunde alles andere als gut. Wenn man das Potenzial sieht von Monaco, hat man keine Stammkraft ziehen lassen im Sommer. Man wollte in der Champions League angreifen, ist in den Playoffs ausgeschieden gegen Csácia Donetsk. Natürlich waren man in der Winterpause nur 4 Punkte von Platz 3, aber auch nur 4 Punkte von Platz 12. Spielärisch, was die Monaco-Gassen gezeigt haben, war alles andere als zielstrebig. Niko Kovac hat es nicht geschafft, das Potenzial dieser Mannschaft auszuschöpfen. Es gab schon immer wieder Reibungen mit einigen Spielern, insbesondere mit Kapitänen der DDR, der immer wieder auf der Bank saß oder frühzeitig ausgewechselt wurde. Es war ein bisschen das Verhältnis wie in München mit Thomas Müller für Niko Kovac. Man sieht, nach einem halben Jahr ist es schwer für Kovac, die komplette Kabine hinter sich zu haben. Laut einigen Spielern war er auch zu streng, zu direkt, zu militärisch. Das hat einigen nicht gepasst. Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe mich viel in Frankreich umgehört. Man war schon überrascht, dass Kovac gehen musste, weil er schon ein gutes Bild in Frankreich hatte. Man war froh, so einen Namen zu haben. Er hat trotzdem eine gute Arbeit geleistet, aber nicht gut genug für die russischen Oligarchen. Das sind die Eigentümer mit dem Chef Ribo Loeffleif. Er hat gesehen, dass er der Mannschaft keinen guten Fußball bietet und dass man sehr weit weg von Paris Saint-Germain ist. Man wollte PSG angreifen in dieser Saison, sodass man lieber sich von Kovac getrennt hat und ihn durch den Belgier Philipp Clément ersetzt hat, der bei Brügge war. Und jetzt ist man plötzlich wieder auf Champions League Kurs. Und nicht zu vergessen, Kovac hat auch Monaco auf dem ersten Platz der Europa League Gruppe geführt, vor Real Sociedad San Sebastian, vor Eindhoven und sogar vor Sturm Graz. Also war es eigentlich nicht so schlecht, aber es hat nicht ganz gereicht.
Und würdest du sagen, dass das Bild von Nico Kovac als Trainer gelitten hat jetzt durch diese Entlassung? Es ist ja schon interessant, dass man wieder von Problemen mit einzelnen Spielern hört.
Du meinst ihn im Hinblick vielleicht auf eine baldige Zukunft in Deutschland?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich da jetzt draufkomme.
Borussia Dortmund vielleicht sogar. Dann hat sein Bild ja nicht gelitten. Ja, er hat schon einen guten Ruf in Deutschland. Sobald er in Monaco entlassen wurde, hat man gehört, wo könnte Kovac gut gebaut werden? In einigen namhaften Clubs wird es bald eine freie Stelle geben. Vielleicht wird es Dortmund, vielleicht Borussia Mönchengladbach, vielleicht wird es Hertha. Aber er will sicherlich zu einem ambitionierten Verein, wo er die Mannschaft in die Champions League führen kann. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sein Ruf darunter leiden wird, weil wenn man über Kovac spricht in Deutschland, habe ich das Gefühl, hätte man immer von einem Kovac, der Frankfurt zum Pokalsieg geführt hat und nicht unbedingt der in München gescheitert ist. Ich bin sicher, dass Kovac im Sommer in der Bundesliga zurück ist, und zwar bei einem der zwei Büros hier.
Okay, sehr gut. Alexi lehnt sich gern aus dem Fenster, das mag ich. Dann habe ich jetzt noch eine abschließende Frage, die jeder von euch beantworten darf. Alex, du darfst mal beginnen. Welcher Spieler aus La Liga macht dir denn aktuell am meisten Freude?
Oha, da werde ich jetzt unvorbereitet erwischt. Ich sage, ich beantworte das mal nicht ganz fachgerecht. Ich sage, ich freue mich sehr auf Ferran Torres, den Neuzugang des FC Barcelona. Der hat ja noch nichts geleistet. Der kam ja nämlich noch nicht in La Liga zum Einsatz. Wird aber jetzt zum Einsatz kommen, zum ersten Mal am Wochenende. Darauf freue ich mich.
Warum kann jetzt auf einmal Barca wieder Spieler verpflichten?
Tja, weil man Geld gefunden hat in den Sofa-Ritzen. Schlanke 55 Millionen. Weil sie tatsächlich die Ablöse so mehr stückelen, wie das im Fußball völlig normal ist. Also sprich, sie zahlen diese 55 Millionen nicht auf einmal, sondern auf die, ich meine, sogar 5 Jahre Vertragsdauer.
Na, das kann ja nur gut gehen.
Und die erste Charge wird erst im Sommer fällig. Also sie zahlen im Sommer nur, was sind das, dann 11, 14, 15, irgendwie sowas dann, Millionen. Also es ist nicht so viel, wenn man es über die Laufzeit abstottert. Das ist der eine Grund. Der andere Grund sind natürlich, sie nehmen ja trotzdem Geld ein. Sie haben Champions League gespielt und das Stadion ist wieder voller. Et cetera, et cetera. Also es fließt Geld. Sie konnten die Gehälter ein bisschen zurückschrauben. Der ein oder andere verzichtet auf Geld. Und so konnten sie ein bisschen was einnehmen. Und geben es gerne wieder aus.
Also Ferran Torres ist der Spieler der Wahl von Alex. Christian, welcher Spieler aus der Serie A macht hier gerade so richtig Freude? Also da ich ja davon ausgehe, dass jetzt sehr viele Offensivspieler genannt werden, hier gerade bei solchen Kategorien, gehe ich mal vielleicht ein bisschen in die andere Richtung und nenne Alessandro Bastoni von Inter. Innenverteidiger aus der Dreierkette. Also ich weiß schon, er ist ja Teil des Europameisterschaftskaders, absoluter Stammspieler auch schon unter Konter. Also das ist jetzt keine, wie soll man sagen, große Neuigkeit. Aber ich finde, er entwickelt sich nochmal großartig weiter. Ist auch so ein bisschen symbolisch für die neue spielerische Freiheit, Leichtigkeit, die Simone Insagi bei Inter gebracht hat nach diesem sehr dogmatischen Antonio Conte-Fußball. Da hat man das Gefühl, dass da alles so ein bisschen befreiter aufspielen, auch wirklich auch offensiv andere Abläufe da sind. Und Pastoni ist da weit viel, viel mehr als nur einer aus der Dreierkette. Der hat sich zuletzt immer wieder Tore vorbereitet, selber getroffen gegen Lazio 1, vorbereitet per Flanke. Wo man sich vielleicht fragt, oh, da war er zufälligerweise auf der linken Außenbahn. War aber kein Zufall, weil er sich, weil er Teil dieses Insagesystems ist, dass auch mindestens immer einer aus der Dreierkette sich wirklich weit bis mit nach vorne mit einschaltet, oft auch direkt am Strafraum beteiligt. Und er ist auch auf dem Weg, wirklich so ein richtiger Leader zu werden bei Inter. Er und Barella zusammen sind die zwei jungen Italiener, die da auch für die Zukunft von Inter stehen. Und Inter steht ja auch nicht ganz schlecht da. Deswegen würde ich mal Herrn Bastoni nennen. Sehr gute Wahl. Hendrik, wer aus der Premier League macht dir Spaß?
Um vielleicht mal einen der weniger offensichtlichen Spieler zu nennen, würde ich Jared Bone von West Ham United nennen. West Ham spielt ja wieder mal eine starke Saison, das vierte Moment. Und Jared Bone rechts außen ist da einer der entscheidenden Spieler mit jetzt schon sechs Toren und neun Vorlagen. Also spielt eine ganz starke Saison. Gilt auch so ein bisschen als Außenseiterkandidat für die englische Nationalmannschaft und die WM, gerade da Harry Kane in dieser Saison noch nicht so richtig in Fahrt kommt. Und ist auch ein Spieler, der immer wieder genannt wird, zum Beispiel in Verbindung mit dem FC Liverpool. Genau, also Jared Bone von West Ham ist ein Spieler, den man sich anschauen sollte.
Und jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob Alexi Leo Messi sagt oder jemand anderen. Alexi, wer macht dir in der Liga Freude?
Natürlich könnte ich sagen, Kylian Mbappé, der ein Tor an dem anderen erzählt und der momentan wirklich der wahre Chef geworden ist von PSG, weil Messi ihn immer verletzt oder keine Lust haben. Aber ich bin auch ein bisschen Fan von Außenseitern. Und bei Racing Club de Lens gibt es einen, der nicht mehr lange in der Liga bleiben kann, weil er einfach zu stark ist. Ja, es ist Eko Fofanar und Christian Kendin, denke ich mal, weil er bei Udiné war vor ein paar Jahren. Und während er stark ist, er kann wirklich alles, als 6er, 8er, Bälle zurückerobern, technisch nach vorne, mit Bälle in die Tiefe, zweikampfstark, dynamisch und sehr, sehr konstant vor allem. Er ist auf dem Zettel einiger Vereine. Bernly hat vor ein paar Tagen 17 Millionen Euro angeboten, hat Lons natürlich nur zu einem Lächeln gebracht. Und wenn ihr Lust habt auf die Liga 1 und zumindest einen neuen Spieler entdecken möchtet, dann guckt ihr den mal an, weil er macht einfach Spaß.
Vorfahrener werden wir uns angucken. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Ich mach das jetzt mal im Kollektiv. Danke euch, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Wer euch folgen möchte in den diversen sozialen Netzwerken, der findet alle Links in den Show Notes. Danke, dass ihr hier wart. Ja, gerne. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ihr könnt noch mitmachen, das ist mir tatsächlich noch wichtig. Auf dkms.de/rasenfunkkönntihr euch als Spender registrieren lassen. Wir machen da gerade zusammen mit einigen anderen Fußball-Podcasts eine Registrierungsaktion. Und was soll ich sagen? Wir haben plötzlich einen Gegner. Nachdem der Rasenfunk lange die Registrierungsliste angeführt hat, ist jetzt Bundesliga mit dazu gekommen. Also ihr müsst euch bitte registrieren oder jemanden aktivieren, dass er sich registriert, wenn ihr es schon seid. dkms.de/rasenfunkistfür eine gute Sache. Wir helfen damit Menschen, die eine Blutkrebsdiagnose bekommen haben. Und allein während dieser Sendung sind das, mal kurz im Kopf überschlafen, 6 Menschen, die im Durchschnitt gesehen diese Diagnose bekommen haben. Und ihr könnt den Rasenfunk finanziell unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Auch unsere Gäste bekommen eine Honorar. Danke für eure Unterstützung, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.